casi ocho años después de la
desaparición de 43 estudiantes en iguala
mexico y con varias versiones
manipuladas de lo que pasó con ellos aún
no se sabe la verdad los jóvenes
desaparecieron el 26 de septiembre de
2014 y sus familias siguen reclamando
por justicia el más reciente informe del
grupo interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes de la cdh señala que la
marina mexicana manipuló evidencia sobre
el caso al intervenir en el basurero que
fue señalado por el gobierno del
entonces presidente enrique peña nieto-
como el sitio donde los restos de los
jóvenes habrían sido incinerados una
versión conocida como la verdad
histórica los estudiantes de la escuela
normal rural de ayotzinapa estaban bajo
vigilancia en tiempo real por parte del
estado antes y durante su secuestro pues
su universidad que tiene fuertes lazos
con los movimientos sociales de
izquierda en el país ha sido vista como
un foco potencial de subversión la
conversación sobre esta noticia es con
ángela buitrago ella es ex fiscal e
integrante del grupo interdisciplinario
de expertos independientes sobre el caso
de los 43 normalistas de ayotzinapa
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
fueron asesinados 20 testigos clave para
dar con el paradero de los estudiantes
desaparecidos lo dijo el jurista chileno
francisco couso durante la presentación
del tercer informe del grupo
interdisciplinario de expertos del 28 de
marzo quienes son los cinco asesinados y
quién los mató
buenos días gracias por la invitación
angela y la verdad es que a lo largo de
estos años que han transcurrido han
asesinado a varios de los presuntos
responsables de los hechos que fueron
dejados en libertad por las torturas
cometidas por la detención y frente a la
investigación
varios de ellos habían sido detenidos
varios de ellos se decía sean parte del
grupo delictivo y sobre esos supuestos
fueron asesinados a medida que iban
saliendo de la cárcel y también
posteriormente fue
algo que está en investigación
ejecutado al parecer una persona que iba
a ser capturada para ser detenida porque
tenía mucha información sobre los hechos
de esta situación fue puesta de presente
el año pasado cuando se ordenó una
captura desde hace más de año y medio no
se había ejecutado ante la presión para
que se realice esta captura deciden
ejercer las acciones correspondientes si
bien es cierto el andaba armado con un
revólver y dispara el lente tiros
inclusive en el cuello y en la cabeza lo
cual lleva ya también a entender que
debe investigarse este hecho porque era
una persona que sabía mucho el caso en
particular de los estudiantes cómo se
logró acceder al material y de la
evidencia videográfica que permitió al
grupo de expertos llegar a las
conclusiones del tercer informe
bueno la forma como nosotros llegamos es
manejando las hipótesis que se habían
dejado abiertas en el momento en que se
retira el gen de méxico en el año 2016
revisando a cada uno de los elementos
que se había agregado dentro de la
investigación bien declaraciones bien
documentos y finalmente la apertura de
los archivos militares y la entrega
también parcial de una información
complementada con la revisión que se
hizo en archivos por parte del juez y de
la cob acá en este caso en particular se
recibieron
miles de documentos tenemos casi tres
ternas de documentación y sobre esos
supuestos el análisis la evaluación y la
concentración de la información de
manera contextual nos permiten llegar a
las afirmaciones que se hacen en el
tercer informe ángel el gobierno de
lópez obrador dijo que un grupo de
marinos son investigados por la
manipulación en el basurero de cocula
pero se negó a dar más datos sin embargo
ha asegurado en otras ocasiones anv lo
que está entregando toda la información
usted qué opina
lo primero es que gracias a la decisión
del presidente efectivamente se está
entregando toda la información que había
sido cerrada que había sido reservada y
que inclusive nos habían negado en
nuestra en nuestro primer mandato fue
con la firma en el año 2018 y con el
regreso del gía y que insistimos en el
año 2020 e insistimos en la presentación
de todos los documentos y en la
exhibición de los documentos que sean
parte de la noche del 26 y 27 de
septiembre del 2014 en las instalaciones
de marina de sedena de existen obtener
esa información incluso muchos de ellos
vídeos muy comprometedores en torno a
cómo se desarrolló la investigación
encontramos también que toda la
información que se obtiene en primer
lugar es una información bajo tortura lo
cual ya nos lleva a una decisión
categórica de tener en cuenta este hecho
para deslegitimar obviamente la
investigación pero sobre todo para
reconducir a una investigación
garantías los resultados que se den
desde ahí también debemos decir que
cuando nosotros encontramos muchos de
estos documentos otros no se hayan o no
se entregan por parte de la marina y por
perdón por parte de sedena
posteriormente ese semar
marina nos aparece en el panorama en
otros elementos y hechos que no sabíamos
que han existido gracias a la
información que recogemos de sedena
desde ahí entonces podemos decir y
aclarar para todos ustedes sedena ese
ejército de mares marina y eso lleva a
que nosotros entonces en octubre del año
pasado pidamos al presidente la
instrucción para que se entregue todo lo
que tiene ese mar lo cual se nos entrega
en la visita siguiente a esa reunión de
octubre y encontramos los vídeos que
fueron presentados en donde se ve
claramente que un presunto lugar y
decimos presunto porque en ese momento
había sido no solamente parte de una
indagación indebida con tortura sino
posiblemente un lugar señalado por otras
personas se afectó de manera nociva en
el tema de la obtención de la
información y obviamente de la forma
como ustedes pudieron ver en ese vídeo
se llega a recuperar ese sitio mire en
los dos primeros informes del gía y se
señala que hubo una operación dirigida
durante el gobierno de peña nieto en la
que participaron distintas entidades
oficiales para realizar un montaje sobre
lo que pasó con estas desapariciones qué
implicaciones habrá algún día para el ex
presidente
nosotros lo que hemos sido categóricos
es que todo lo que hemos investigado
lleva a una serie de simulaciones de
ocultamientos y de falsedades que
fíjense cómo inclusive encontramos
también categóricamente que las actas
que llevan a ciertos lugares o que
tratan de justificar las detenciones de
ciertos presos fueron falsas esto ha
sido un trabajo muy fuerte por la unidad
especializada de investigación y
litigación willy acá en donde se ha
podido seguir paso a paso y hemos podido
acompañarla de manera de coadyuvantes
cómo se han construido todos estos
documentos dos como también se
construyeron informaciones desde
llamadas anónimas que nunca existieron y
esto lo que permite decir es que todos
por lo menos tienen que informar qué fue
lo que pasó hasta donde supieron cómo
conocieron porque si no esto es una
cadena interminable de actos de
simulación que denunciábamos
específicamente en la presentación del
tercer informe